est on en repart tu prends mon petit
fils est pourquoi l ami nous sommes de
retour sur player renault battleground
ce jeudi morency addict et sur lequel je
me débrouille de temps à eau alors je
vais me faire visiter ses terres déjà
battu par des centaines de milliers de
personnes avant - ses sentiers battus du
plus éloignées au plus proche de nos
contrées messieurs dames bienvenue dans
ce deuxième épisode de la visite du
guide twizy est ce qu'il est fort aux
jeux vidéo
pour commencer bien sûr tous les cours
sont situés ok bah non si je suis pas on
va casser vécu mais qu'on va aller à 4k
bien sûr contrées éloignées de la
province charnois n'est that eut connu
la province cheikh doit neige est un mec
qui est descendu avec moi au caire est
dans ses petits pâtés de maisons là on
va pas y toucher dans une grosse ville
parce que finalement le battleground
c'est pas que putching qui ouvre aux
actus tout comme le japon n'y a pas
qu'au tokyo alors je vais vous faire
visiter d'abord tout ce qui est un petit
peu rural al aoussat vote le pen ou
c'est bien meilleur insiste quand une
seule excuse est moyen mais qu il va te
pètes personne ne votera le pen dans
cette vidéo mon pote tu vas te faire
[ __ ] allez faut qu'on trouve énorme
avant lui le premier trou j'ai gagné
j'ai gagné il est où personne
aujourd'hui voilà ça m'a fait du bien
bon alors à et des bruits mais rentre et
je prends mon avocat où est ta carte
électorale
ah c'est pas un bureau de vote ici pas
moi ce que je suis déchaînez mais là ça
fait du bien alors encore un les normes
tu fais quoi avec un pied-de-biche
[ __ ] mais c'est pas vrai je me suis
mis archi bien sûr ce début de game
alors alors bon finition de fouiller
c'est ce bureau de vote finalement peu
vite désormais et présidentielle c'est
fini donc ça dégage ou du coup ils ont
fouillé les trouver en tout il y avait
rien non mais c'est pas possible c'est
forcément quelque chose un endroit où
ils sont tous venus une fois alors
qu'ils n'ont même pas fouillés aux
alentours rien et y avait un fusil à
pompe et son compte voilà le but les
avis est de stuff à mort avant de
rejoindre les grandes villes finalement
de faire l'exode
rural ouais des fois j'ai petit souvient
du collège qui reviennent ouais y'a un
mec on va lui dire bonjour ou pas il
s'est gouré [ __ ] mais qui n'a pas vu
que le bureau de vote c'était là bas ou
alors on va lui rendre visite afin lui
tirer les vers du nez à celui-là lé ou
contre toi n'est pas le bureau de vote
manga ici une situation très commune à
ce village de l'alsace c'est quand
[Musique]
voilà quand aucun des deux ne se dire
pour jour à l'autre et était timide dans
ce village qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
voir des gens on va tout lui prendre
bien sûr car nous sommes des bandits
tout à fait bon bah les amis on a
maintenant dézinguer des quatre
habitants de ce village d'alsace on les
a vus dans les campagnes allons les voir
dans les villes et alors on va se
diriger vers mes revers vrr ici alors
s'il y avait quelqu'un par ici mon ami
mais où te caches tu mon ami je sais tu
étais ici et là personne n'en fait le
village voisin au village de charente
sommes bien sûr c'est le visage de
charente ou non
on y arrive je crois qu'il ya personne
ici alors on va aller vers la bas
jusqu'au un passement de balle de sniper
on n'est jamais à l'abri ici champs de
blé bien sûr parce qu il faut savoir que
le vidage de charentonne et de charente
our jeu puisqu'il a dit merde vivent
essentiellement de l'agriculture c'est
pour ça qu'on y retrouve pas mal de
champs 1 comme comme celui dans lequel
nous sommes actuellement au jour d'où
venons en paix on va pas voler le
recteur vous en faites pas oui on est
intrigant oui nous venons de ramasser un
sniper son partenaire à l'écran pas à
bruit ça c'est le guide concurrents qui
m'a volé la moitié des clients sur un an
on arrive on arrive où on arrive on
arrivé là il sait qu'on est là sinon et
sortir il sait qu'il a fait du bruit et
qu'il a attiré lauvray guide de ces
lieux à on l'a vu regarder il est là bas
je serai tué le faux guides qui me vole
mes clients en les faisant payer un euro
moins cher le ticket est en fait je fais
le malin mais quand j'ai abandonné mon
père sous deux secondes je me rends
compte que je suis en stress amorce de
30 kw à regarder le lui là bas
et oui mais qu'est ce que tu viens
j'aime plus de vannes en fait je tue
trop de gens dans nombre de votes que
j'arrive à développer ce terrible pour
prendre le véhicule de manière à
s'extirper de la zone rouge et vert
politique qui verrait grandes villes ce
bar tu as quoi faire c'est qu'on m'a
vraiment camper aux extrémités du champ
de force c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire
pour gagner en fait il ya des tirs
attention ça vient de loin ça ça vient
de loin comme la fouine arrive bientôt -
on y va à pied le buggy c'est trop
grillé ça fait trop de bruit faudra un
moteur électrique y en a pas rejoignant
la zone le blème sait que l'on va se
retrouver face à des gens qui campent
dans ces bâtiments comme les pires fdp
de l'histoire de la planète mais j'ai un
plan b si nous tirent dessus on saute
dans l'eau et on va sous lourd quand et
sous l'hôtel principe dans je n'en ai
pas pourquoi c'est pas moi qui les fais
mais un mec au dessus je vous le dis
j'ai entendu je pense qu'un mec sur le
toit non bon le guide et perdu les amis
c'est l'une des rares fois où le guide
est perdu il ne sait pas quoi faire
ok le chanteur ça il faut y aller tu es
un mec me tire dessus pendant que je
fais chaque force et injuste dès qu'on
aura passé la montagne sert à mieux mais
là à
[Musique]
et voilà donc allait bien quelqu'un sur
le toit qui campaient qui attendait
bravo le guide apprécié de prendre sa
retraite
ou alors qu'il est vraiment séparé
manière dont notre si belle messieurs
dames bienvenue dans la province de gap
qu'à un espace agréable plein de verdure
et de plats il n'ya rien aux alentours
tes courses tu te démerdes pour les
faire mais bon c'est une ville qui vit
du tourisme qui vit donc grâce à vous
qui regardez cette vidéo car vous êtes
les touristes dans cette vidéo et je
suis le guide ça c'est fait allez on
n'en parle plus fins papa papa papa pour
la clairement on est entre tous les
bâtiments si c'est la fête des voisins
vos potes on dément clairement à bc laon
s'étaient régalés tout à l'heure alors
tout la petite poêle ça protège le
derrière regarder ça ça empêchera les
balles j'attends votre coccyx sait très
bien ce pas une blague en plus c'est la
vérité ah je sais qu'un malentendu
mais si la part de vouloir se joindre à
la visite vous l'avez vu
non l'avez vu il m'a vit mal le mec il
était à sa fenêtre depuis 20 minutes
quoi tu me la frappa on sait très bien
que tu étais pas avec un verre de rosé
en train de mater la nature espèce de
mythe au t1 train de mater le cul du
guide pour lui mettre une balle dedans
c'est tout ce que tu es en train de
faire à monsieur le campeur qu'est-ce
que vous avez pour moi on a une petite
fille car elle va nous manquer ça tient
bon bah excellence à merci mon ami bon
bah les dom où on doit diriger vers la
prochaine zone qui est à pau ching qui à
quelques pas d'ici c'est une vie qu'on
n'a pas encore visité ça me rend heureux
voilà j'ai le smile alalala sion se fait
tirer dessus c'est comme tout à l'heure
on est des gens les plus vulnérables
d'europe et c'est fini mais on à la
poêle qui protège nos fesses rien et on
la voit bien les amis nous arrivons à
poutine qui est sa merveilleuse
cathédrale justice'' classé patrimoine
historique bien sûr bolas une petite
ville sympa dans laquelle nora man tu
vas dès le début quand tu as des
couilles et ce n'est pas mon cas au la
prochaine zone est tellement noir faut y
aller faut concours dès maintenant on
n'a pas le temps allait allen ne
stressez pas suivez le guide tout va
bien se passer vous en faites pas en
plus le guide est totalement soirée
comme vous pouvez le voir vraiment pas
de quoi avoir peur
olivier une voiture y ait ce choc clos
mais qui l'a mis là et quand d'un
endroit ils attendent quelqu'un monde de
natation de merde
après les fêtes arrivent sont elles pas
en danger parce qu'on va acheter des
requêtes [ __ ] à léona attention ça va
bien tout va bien [ __ ] d'achat nous
annonce qu'on est parmi les dix neuf
survivants de cette visite tuer vous
tuez moi moi j'entretiens mes visiteurs
quelqu'un veut un petit bonbon quelqu'un
dit moi je vous mets bien aux jeunes
fois que ça serait triste y aura plus de
bâtiments avec une battle à base de gens
cachés derrière des arbres le guide est
sous pression
ça court de partout la lumière
chez vous tous soit jusqu'au dernier
moment comme un lâche faut y aller la
piste de but de caen par quoi poirot est
sûre de toi là mais qu'il n'y a pas pu
coller à la zone que nous on peut le
faire les amis on peut le faire auprès
gardien sa jeunesse que le dit pas gagné
j'appelais je pleure pas parce que je
vous ai fait déçu je pleure parce que
j'ai frôlé la caisse et les amis de
cette visite guidée j'espère que vous a
plu c'est qu'elle n'hésitait pas à
mettre un sur cinq sur tes pas de visa
c'était hyper drôle tu adhères vidéo que
je faisais sur ce jeu j'avais envie de
refaire russe pascal la presse et vous
avez bien plus et ça m'avait bien plu
aussi ce jeu me met la pression mais
c'est un truc de malade commune et la
pression c'est terrible c'est astronomie
on a fini 5e ont pour être fiers de nous
bravo et puis je sais miroir
[Musique]